labor day kicking off a busy week on the
campaign trail
with less than two months to go until
election day both presidential tickets
are hitting up crucial swing states
vice president mike pence and senator
kamala harris spending today in
wisconsin while joe biden is in
pennsylvania president trump meanwhile
holding a labor day news conference at
the white house
where he touted the economic comeback
and unleashed a flood of attacks on joe
biden
we are in the midst of the fastest
economic recovery in
u.s history by contrast biden
presided over the worst the weakest and
the slowest
economic recovery since the great
depression under
my leadership next year will be the
greatest economic year in the history of
our country
biden and his very liberal running mate
the most liberal person in congress by
the way
is not a competent person in my opinion
would destroy this
country and would destroy this economy
and those stocks will crash like you've
never seen before biden's plan
for the china virus is to shut down the
entire us economy he wants to
surrender our jobs to china our jobs and
our economic well-being
but the biden campaign has some attacks
of their own here's kamala harris
hitting trump on the economic recovery
and his response to the coronavirus
pandemic
donald trump has been an abject failure
and incompetent when it comes to
addressing
the severe job loss that has happened as
a result of the pandemic
because he has failed to address the
pandemic itself his perspective for too
long is to talk about
how well the economy is doing based on
how rich people are doing
we need to talk about how the economy is
doing based on how working people are
doing
uh speaking of working people greg
gutfeld
happy labor day hey thank you
thank you look who's in you know i uh
uh first off i got to say look who's in
for dana it looks like the barbie
beetlejuice has
[Laughter]
don't listen arrived him you're like the
hamburglar's assistant
i think you look great did you escape
from bubble gum prison
poor thing you look beautiful
you don't have to save her she looks
like she's on the smurf rugby team
all right i'll shut up now i have more
by the way
you do you look like the spokesperson
for a candy land
okay you look good i like my job
it would be a great job you would be
great because you're the actual size as
the pieces from candy land
so you could actually go there and have
press conferences
should i should i address this topic or
am i done for this eight block
yes just give us like half of what you
were gonna say greg
all right imagine in 1906 the mayor of
san francisco gets blamed for the
earthquake
that's essentially what the the
democratic game plan is for the pandemic
they're assuming the public is so stupid
that we didn't realize how great the
economy was before the pandemic
and so when they bring up this argument
all it does is it
causes the republicans to point out the
explosive job growth before
and the job growth that's coming back
and it shows you that trump was really
good
he was like a squirrel in which he
stored all these nuts
i.e jobs for the winter and the winter
came the pandemic
so instead of defending nuts on the
street
he stored them for the winter and saved
our economy
wow the squirrel metaphor i hadn't heard
that one yet greg
um uh dana i'm gonna let you um respond
to the personal attacks and then you can
talk about
today's economic debate
well i wore this sweater on purpose
because one he's
he said i would never wear it again and
i had to prove him wrong and secondly i
just felt like today needed a little
lift i mean
only only the four or five of us working
on labor day here we are
um but it's a pleasure of course to be
with you all
um so traditionally the labor day
holiday
is the start of the campaign when
everybody in the country really starts
to focus
i think that people have been highly
engaged in this campaign for quite a
while but let's just say that that's
true
if you are looking for signs that the
com the country is returning to normal
after dealing with the pandemic you
might look at the campaign trail today
and say
oh things must be getting better because
now both all four candidates the two
vice presidential candidates the two
presidential candidates
are out there they're making the case
for their candidacy
they're attacking one another and giving
us a lot to talk about
so i think in a way when i thought about
that this morning i said that is
good news i think that the president has
a lot to talk about in terms of saying
remember how the economy was and then
what i had to do
i i'm telling you i can get us back to
that place
if he can convince enough people that
that is true then i think that he'll be
in pretty strong position going into
election day
there is one thing i think that both
parties need to focus on
and it should not be a partisan issue
but it's getting this legislation
for an additional cares act done for
people because
a couple of things i just want to point
out back in march when people were
getting furloughed
if you made 50 000 or less 40 percent of
those people in america
lost their jobs if you made a hundred
thousand dollars or more
only 13 of those people lost their jobs
so if you are concerned about that and
we all should be and we should be
focused on
getting those people back you have to
find ways to work
in terms of safety to get people back to
restaurants
gyms all the other jobs that were lost
so that we can get the economy moving
again
regardless of the election or partisan
politics
focusing on those lower income people is
imperative at this point for
the good for the good of our country and
for the good of our citizens
yeah um but nancy's holding it up for um
i think
checks to illegal immigrants and
prisoner releases uh emily compania i
think one of the biggest gifts biden's
given the president so far is when he
answered that rhetorical question about
shutdowns he said yeah i'd shut it down
and people already associated biden with
shutdowns because he wanted them to last
throughout the summer and now
they associate him with future shutdowns
and now the president is really
dialing in on joe the shutdown candidate
and i think that's going to hurt him
that's exactly right jesse and to
piggyback on dana's point
that's the kind of reverberation people
have that they don't want to go through
another shutdown we've already been
through them we know what it's like
it's not a good thing to remind them of
it and to say that you would do it again
we know that the economy is the
strongest topic that the president has
from a messaging standpoint and it's
also
across the polls would americans
consistently rate him higher and have a
higher trust in him
over biden if he can remind them that
yes the economy was super strong before
kovid and also that it's rebounding fast
then it's hard for biden and harris to
argue against it and i think it's
important
that if people start to see a positive
effect in their own lives
then that will be huge for him and final
point oh
i will say that when they hit trump in
the economy
it can sort of have the effect that it
seems that they're rooting against
the economic recovery and so there's a
warning for them in that that that could
bite them
in the foot and final point did you hear
when the vice president reminded
today at the dairyland power cooperative
he reminded the audience there
that senator harris was one of only 10
senators to vote against
the usmca the reaction was palpable
it had a tremendous impact so i think we
should look forward to that moving
forward also
yeah and um geraldo the democrats are
doing something very tricky but i'm
smarter than i look so i figured out
what they're doing
it's very crafty so they don't rate
really well
on the economy biden harris they rate
much better on handling
the pandemic so they don't talk about
their economic policies because they're
unpopular and radical
what they say is in order to fix the
economy
you have to focus on fixing the pandemic
that's how they get around talking about
their economic plans a little sleight of
hand i picked up on it i'm not going to
let it slide
first of all jesse i agree we're in the
midst of a v a sharp v
recovery i mean the the 8.4
unemployment rate totally unexpected at
least a full point
lower than it was anticipated adding
another
million jobs but what the democrats are
doing and it's so obvious to me
they can't attack the economy so what
they're doing is they are
conjuring up a story uh that the
president
called gis losers uh and and
and and attacked the united states
marines
because he didn't want to go to a
ceremony allegedly this is a
hit job i want everyone to understand
what's happening here
i spoke to the president last thursday
morning he brought up
the fact that the marines and bella wood
uh
uh charged into the machine guns can you
believe this the courage of these people
i mean to to to say that he
looked at gi's as losers
is a pathetic detour it's a distraction
from the story of the american people
resiliently
recovering economically with a vaccine
just over the horizon
and for them to impeach the credibility
of that as well
shows that anything goes now anything
goes we're in labor day
now you can stab in the back you can ice
pick in the eye
you can you can you can ice pick in the
eye call someone a
a lack of a patriotism the president
united states
i think it's really uh it's going to
rebound on them i think the president
with his verve and his charisma now is
now getting steam
i want him to not attack biden i want
him to just go
with his program be positive be kind
to people be understanding i think that
he can get this he can use labor day now
to jumpstart his uh campaign
yeah he's going to have a big ad on the
economy out coming up soon and really
hit hard that economic message